[Music]
if you want to get good you have to
sacrifice people are starting to
remember see as go as I remember one
point stick
cs:go felt like they lost hope in many
ways for the second time pronax was one
DOCSIS they cross the middle it's gonna
be a challenge and
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen are you ready for a
counter-strike
[Music]
in order to tell the story of csgo to
understand what it is what it was and
what it will be we need to go back in
time in the beginning back in 1999 and
was the original counter-strike it was
[Music]
owned by the early to mid-2000s CS had
gone from an experiment conducted by a
couple of college kids to an official
valve property and one of the first
truly global eSports the key if without
striking me is very early on it became
like kind of a global gaming it was one
of the first in sport that wasn't just
like a few countries have alien to it or
just one Li Jie's into it's like nearly
the whole world to some degree was
interested in counter-strike the game
was viciously fast-paced but
painstakingly strategic endlessly
sophisticated it's simple enough for a
ten-year-old to understand that wasn't
convoluted or inaccessible it just had a
skill ceiling so high that only a
handful of humans could hit it
it wasn't until the advent of 1.6 in
2003 that counter-strike started
catching sight of its only real problem
it was too good so much so that all the
valves attempts to iterate on it seemed
doomed from the start
first there was the xbox release
unfortunately by this point the console
generation had already begun to take
shape and valves controller oriented
counter-strike was eclipsed by
burgeoning titles like Halo and Call of
Duty then in mid 2004 valve over saw the
release of conditions zero
INRI texturized version of 1.6 that
underwent a series of setbacks delays
and reworks on account of its
third-party developers but the
annoyances around condition 0 were
short-lived since eight months after its
release now published what was both CS
is first true successor and its most
controversial one source it did have
some issues at launch I don't think
there's any doubt about that which did
turn a lot of the people off because
obviously if you've got an existing game
that's been out for years and it's great
managing works perfectly finds it's been
tweaked and then you get something new
and it doesn't quite work obviously
you're gonna stick to the one that you
know and stick to the one that you feel
is complete the criticism laid against
source was simple it didn't feel like
counter-strike valve did implement a
wide array of changes mostly intended to
improve quality of life but a lot of
old-school 1.6 or thought they'd lowered
the skill ceiling most for me what I
believe this that most people kind of
didn't get the same feeling from source
that one would say it's kind of more
like the lost brother or like it felt
plastic the movement wasn't as good and
it's like the way the feel of the game
when playing and shooting like
everything just felt off with that game
the result was a divided a battle
between source apologists and diehards
who refused to abandon the old ways for
eight years the counter-strike community
had to endure a civil war until finally
in 2012 the new hope emerged but before
you're leaving somebody told me to of
God Gabe can you ask him only one
question and I believe many of them
wants to know when are you going to
release
Counter Strike 2
[Music]
[Music]
after ignoring their prized FPS for
nearly a decade valve finally decided to
bless the community with a full-fledged
counter-strike title a place for source
lovers and 1.6 there's alike to take up
arms and assure their game into the next
generation csgo they felt like they lost
hope for counter-strike in many ways and
as soon as it launched the consensus
surrounding Counter Strike global
Offensive was clear it [ __ ] sucked it
was really really bad I remember
complaining about like I mean I'm Ehren
people complain about Molotov recall of
control everything was just different
and everyone was very against it I don't
thing I liked it because you're getting
so used to the game you were playing
before and then you just have to start
of something new and the game isn't
fully evolved and stuff like that so you
know there's coming more updates but
still you're just like what the hell is
this csgo was imbalanced riddled with
bugs and had extremely wonky mechanics
what's more the game was essentially a
combination of one point six source
leaving a large majority of both player
bases dissatisfied how my first official
with table 2 analyst first of all I was
really frustrated because as I said my
career on CS sauce was just starting so
I I didn't know what to expect pretty
much before the first play which was
drug violence er today before in
practice I was terrible my manager was
better than me the Molotov were so
overpowered I think they slowed you down
when you walk through them and they gave
more damage than they do now or
something like that
and you couldn't distinguish them but
there was so many game breaking bugs
people literally predicted that it would
kill counter-strike just a little bit of
hyperbole but it's like a way to sort of
say like that they had gone into the
other direction basically where it's
like it's too much that semi-single csgo
had been dropped by I am no major
tournaments were running it because the
swc was dropping off a cliff at that
point in time essentially it was a
second-tier game but there was one team
that saw csgo
for what it could be a generational
battleground the one true successor to
counter-strike and one of the world's
next big eSport
the team wasn't ninjas in pyjamas a
Swedish super squad who brought together
the best of the best from both 1.6 and
source in an effort to take the csgo
scene by storm and they did so in CSS
early days you essentially had nip who
was made for the game Fryeburg was the
entry frag the flarin was the oppor
exist was the ingame leader and
foresting generator the two star players
which completely rolled over everyone
these five ingredients you had the team
that went 87 and oh now that's a record
that still stands to this day and it
just shows like how dominant they were
in the early days of csgo
sick and tired of watching ni p win
everything in sight other rosters
started to follow suit in addition to
the fact that ni P had lit a fire under
the ass of competitive csgo the game had
improved significantly in the months
following its release the game was
improving very quickly very quickly in
fact much quicker than normally you
expect couple this with the announcement
of the game's first ever major in late
2013 and it was finally starting to feel
as if valve actually cared about
counter-strike so when the Dreamhack
winner tournament was announced for csgo
in 2013 it almost felt like a validation
of the csgo scene and the csgo
competitive scene specifically but this
would only be the first step of what we
would get in the future ni piece first
real challenger came in the form of
french powerhouse very games but soon
another swedish terror rolled around and
they were good enough to surpass ni p oh
how the mighty yep
this forest alone in our one on three I
think we just might pray for it boys
picks up the one kill but he has to
scout these are one or two all Schneider
in there and Jane you'll have to do is
just wait and find time and there it is
they win it and look at the even can't
jumping up one of the most composed
people I think in counter-strike
complete celebration what a victory and
how they deserve it by 2014
csgo had blossomed into everything that
community had hoped for it had become a
full-fledged eSport France Poland and
both of Sweden's best squads had each
secured a major title and the game had
amassed a repertoire of mythological
moments
is to control your nerves in the
situation daunted however might cut
stand the game of oh do they have a
width roost going on currently yes oh my
god this is beautiful you can't squeak
noise while he's here he sees them now
they're straight headshot they have no
idea Smith's looking confused and dazed
okay well then I'd say God's time to
retake didn't break this time they're
feeling more solid care right coming up
from behind the hole so alone
you know one on two throws out another
gray here cats up another kill
is it happening again prone access all
over that bonus in the middle of nowhere
he's gonna sit out here we go yeah right
it's gonna be waiting Eco charges in
dust
[Music]
reactions and here it comes - on 5jw and
flusher there is nothing they can do any
longer ni p have one Gamescom 2014
ladies and gentlemen 1613 it finally
happens then there was the fact that the
games player base had skyrocketed much
of this had to do with the fact that in
late 2013 csgo was given what is perhaps
its most significant feature skins the
skins update was a big change for the
community giving you something you can
buy something that you can customise
your guns it's done where it doesn't
necessarily impact gameplay but it gives
people this exciting element to keep
coming back and keep playing to get more
skins by late 2014 csgo had surged in
popularity and it felt as if the game
had already gotten bigger than anyone
thought was possible then 2015
Kenny yes stuck in the site finding mole
that's brilliant if Kenny yes again oh
my goodness Ken yet there they aren't
rushing this time around they're taking
their sweet time hoping to catch
somebody Picon envious side head well
that's what happens when you go around
the corner happy with wanting debris is
like sweating ball to 50 out jumping and
shooting against one molehill looking
for the study hunted down time is up oh
my god
yeah where you gonna make enemy killing
one second left they just need some
kills here and they will win it for the
second time products is one Friday
[Applause]
[Music]
continues 1513 last nanosecond kill and
look at the guns
sure aw peas phonetic they're ready to
shoot some ducks as they cross the
middle it's gonna be a challenge and not
in this lifetime and ladies and
gentlemen it's gonna require a miracle
and nothing less for happy to make it
out I don't think there's any chance
flusher looking to end this it's
major championship in global Offensive
what
the 15 the counter federal offense
mystery I think that is pretty clear by
this by this moment we saw Katowice
shattered viewership records we watched
the indomitable reign of Kenny s we
cheered at Cologne arguably the greatest
major of all time 2015 was the year that
csgo didn't just boom it exploded is he
gonna try and go huge it
[Applause]
but it also had his fair share of downs
for starters there was the r8 an
obscenely overpowered revolver that
managed to single-handedly destroy the
game in three days before it was nerved
it's like a nightmare the antithesis the
anatomy of everything that
counter-strike is supposed to be in
terms its principles its framework as a
game it's like valve don't understand
the actual core concept tenants the core
tenants the concepts the components that
made CS a great game then there was the
infamous op nerf which sent devotees of
counter-strike single most iconic weapon
into nothing short of an existential
crisis and last but certainly not least
the North American match-fixing scandal
after which members of ibuypower were
famously issued indefinite bans I
thought you guys needed to know that
that actually if I could have got us to
a resolution where the guys just did a
even seasoned ban from steve-o all I
wanted to do was highlight that
match-fixing was real it was going on
people were effectively being defrauded
from their skins in exchange for profits
by 2016 it had become apparent that the
game would have to overcome certain
obstacles if it hoped to keep growing in
the same way League or dota were for
starters it was an eSport in which
counterterrorism was both gamified and
glorified something which potential
investors didn't find very appealing
anything outside of eSports won't go
anywhere near French teams right now
because of because of the climate there
is any chance everyone's interested by
the stats that CS brings but as soon as
they hear terrorists again some
terrorism unlike League dota and the
recently released overwatch CS wasn't
cartoonish and family-friendly it was a
milsim driven bloodbath one whose
photorealistic guns and incessant gore
made for difficult conversations and
sales and marketing meetings
I love the analogy that I that I also
try and bring up all the time to UFC
they have the same problem how do they
find sponsorships for the UFC you have
an octagon in which people are you know
quite literally bleeding on the company
logos that are sponsoring them you're
only gonna find like handful sponsors
that are in on that there was also the
issue of cheated following the back ban
of French opera Kali in 2014 and
suspicions around North American
up-and-comer Sabrosa two years later a
hysteria started to develop around the
idea that players could be cheating on
land these allegations aren't coming
from online games these allegations
coming from land in this instance
actually seems to community
overwhelmingly believes that this guy is
a cheese and let's not forget the fact
that by 2016
skin gambling was reported to have
become a billion-dollar industry things
came to a head when youtubers team
Martin and Pro syndicate started
marketing a lottery site that they
happened to own a fact they failed to
disclose to their viewers and we found
this new site called csgo lotto so I'll
link it down in description if you guys
want to check it out but we were betting
on it today and I won a pot of like 69
dollars or something like that so it's a
pretty small pot it resulted in an FTC
investigation 23 cease and desist
letters and several class-action
lawsuits against valve for condoning
underage gambling but the biggest
obstacle facing csgo was the fact that
valve the very developer who brought
counter-strike to the masses didn't seem
to care whether or not it succeeded okay
counter-strike works now this guy just
gonna go like that and I'm dead do you
literally see like his [ __ ] shoulder
patch and you just died from a pistol
from that far away god gaben you suck so
much penis at making video games it
[ __ ] hurts me bro
it [ __ ] you're so rich it's insane
how could you not fix this [ __ ] game
sorry what if this had to do with the
fact that since csgo is launched in 2012
valve had put nearly all of their eggs
in the dota basket from a multi-million
dollar tournament to an engine overhaul
to a never-ending sea of skins feature
implementations gameplay updates and
seasonal events doh
had everything an enthusiast can ask for
csgo on the other hand it's because
people are starting to get over scans a
little bit and counterstrikes going back
to where it was supposed to be and that
is before the skins came out the game
was really not very far really not doing
that well in competitive standpoint but
the community persevered in fact it was
around this time that CS saw the rise of
a new generation of competitors
competitors who were young enough that
they'd come up on go the result was an
influx of players who'd grown impossibly
attuned to the games complex mechanics
it was also around this time that csgo
started to solidify itself as a truly
international eSport 2016 saw one of one
point six is single most dominating
regions make a thunderous return to the
world of counter-strike
Brazil comes once again the first base
is the trainees gonna hit the ground
there's cold
how does he do this told us safely
velocity with you'll play Guardian
versus taco it may just be destined to
fade and it's throwing off the team
winning their first major championship
trying to walk through the smoke but
it's just not gonna happen sk-gaming
second major championship in a row they
are your way
and by 2017 more contenders than ever
were entering the fray from the
long-awaited resurgence of the Danes
Pasha coming in with a refract but he's
down the bomb has been picked up by
Dupree to one of the greatest cinderella
stories in counterstrike history I just
say all of place that I Laurie or and
second north helped me and they wore
measure
2017 was the year that csgo entered a
new era of competitive play one in which
no single region could rightfully exert
superiority over the others and rosters
were diversifying as a result dominate
New York to 2017 to the Barclays center
all the way through this tournament
they've looked so so good still it felt
as if the game was continuously be
bottlenecked
and had plateaued as if this adored
eSport was faded to play second fiddle
to the newer flash year titles in terms
of popularity sustainability and
acceptance all because it had an absent
and uncaring developer valve just
sitting up on high and then every now
and then suddenly like 10 cows fall over
dead and we're all supposed to in queue
at what does I mean and the angry with
all babies because of what we said about
the RA like this is not a reasonable
state of affairs for again that's making
hundreds of millions of dollars the
future of csgo didn't necessarily look
grim it just didn't look as bright as
the community felt it should be with
TI's prize pool becoming increasingly
absurd and franchising being touted as
the future of eSports it felt as if
slowly but surely counter-strike was
being overshadowed and then in January
of 2018 something momentous happened
after this round we're either going to
overtime or we're crowning a new major
champion were handing away a trophy in
this next round potentially something so
historic that it brought the gaming
world to its feet nothing else is going
on he's on
[Applause]
they came back all the way oh
in a year when a billion-dollar battle
royale became the most played video game
and creation when franchising became a
reality when streaming fortnight and
ninja somehow became synonymous with
eSports a year in which OD Cinderella
their way to the ages in the most
miraculous way imaginable and IG
liberated League of Legends from the
tyranny of South Korea five North
American misfits banded together in
Boston bruised battered and bled their
way to the finals of a major and put on
the performance that shattered one of
Twitch's most coveted viewership records
in the corner with the AWP but do they
realize this I think he's been spotted
now I don't have a smoke toy to play
with you can delay them if you can
occupy their attention long enough his
teammates can make the play just by
staying there
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
do you know what that noise means that
it means it's match point cloud nine
again there they reminded the world of
something that it never should have
forgotten in the first place that no
matter who they are where they are or
whatever other games they might enjoy
whether they're nerds normies or
something in between people show up for
counter-strike
[Music]
for the period
[Music]
of youth waits patiently
the pushup
[Applause]
dick can't watch the phaser
[Music]
[Applause]
it has to be one of the most incredible
storylines we've ever had
counter-strike
isn't just a game it's a way of life a
culture a community one of the oldest
institutions in all of eSports one of
the biggest things about counter-strike
just how it's always been evolving but
yet with fundamentals of it haven't
really changed at all and it's community
involvement that I think it's been so
big to the growth of it over time it's a
20 year old half-life mod with awful
graphics outdated mechanics and a shitty
sound engine and yet it remains the
crown jewel of fps is the og the goat
the most storied serious prestigious
enduring and competitive shooter the
world has ever seen the medium for
clicking heads against which all others
are judged and by 2019 it felt like
people were starting to remember that
[Music]
like there'd been a call to action back
to back yet
back-to-back pro-league parts I
season seven Chicago and now for the
first time ever
same thing let's call another chance to
be holy for the first time in history
the best of all [ __ ] die
and teams were answering it like never
before as if anything were possible if
it's our PK this tropic of in serious
trouble
and Lia's how long can he survive
the way out but he will burn and a
bangle will have themselves a grand
final appearance here in the Berlin
major can you believe it
but they have proved us all wrong
leaving a trend in a bun Melissa's gone
[Applause]
as if everyone from bands to streamers
to players to orgs had found a reason to
get excited about counter-strike again
[Music]
[Music]
and were finally in a position to
capitalize on that excitement it felt
like for the first time in a long time
the future of CS was uncertain in a good
way I had definitely the thing at one
point they were made something assuming
that it works the way that we want the
franchise to work for it doesn't matter
whether you're flicking you're off
flipping your knife winning a major of
rushing B after a few beers you're
engaged in some of the most esteemed and
elemental practices in all of these
sports and whatever happens whatever the
future holds for the beautiful ballistic
thing that we call Counter Strike one
thing is for certain it's not going
anywhere
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else in a part Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]